[Violinist plays Paganini
“Caprice No. 17”]
One of the things that's
so wonderful about the violin is
it is a very difficult
instrument,
which means
you can never be too relaxed
♪
and you always have
to push yourself to be better
every single day.
♪
My name is Ilana Zaks,
and I'm a violinist
at the Yale School of Music
studying in the Master
of Musical Arts program.
♪
How can you present
an experience that is accessible
to as many people as possible?
So I really wanted to bring
history, accessibility, music,
into one space
and to bring it specifically
to Sprague Memorial Hall.
In classical music,
the stage is a little bit
more of a rigid space,
which is why for my recital,
I really wanted to find a way
of bringing
this environment of community
and intimacy into one space.
I really wanted to experiment
with technology,
and I wanted to experiment
with storytelling and in a way
the whole recital is
one big story about history.
♪
You will probably never be able
to recreate that performance,
exactly,
after that moment is done.
♪
What I hope to accomplish in
this performance is
to bring everything
that I've learned here at Yale
into one performance
and to present it to everyone
as a gift from my heart
to the community that
has made my life so special.
♪♪